so we're now talking about what
men want
in the mating strategies when they look
at women
so you're saying small waist
to hip ratio right
is
how much of that
is our deep biological past on top of
which we can build all kinds of
different standards of beauty so you
know we have many
things going on in our brain
our value of other humans in selecting a
mate
might uh incorporate a lot more
variables
as we get into the 21st century so how
quickly does
our
valuation of a mate
uh evolve relative to the evolution of
um
the human species
they're using evolve in the sense of
culturally culturally evolved and then
relative to biologically evolve yeah uh
well i think that there are um
there are some things that are
biologically evolved some standards
standards of attractiveness
um and there are some of the things that
i mentioned so in male evaluation of
females
let me back up and just say what is the
underlying logic why would we have
standards of attractiveness so
um
here's the interesting thing and this
gets back to your earlier question about
what is
unique to humans or what distinguishes
us or what set us off on the path that
we did
is
chimpanzee males
do not have any difficulty
figuring out when a female is fertile
she signals that like crazy with the
bright red genital swell swelling uh
olfactory cues she goes into estrus
in humans we have and this was actually
a third thing that i wanted to add
earlier
we have concealed ovulation okay
relatively concealed ovulation which is
remarkable given how close we are
primatologically to to chimpanzees
and so um uh there's there's a little
bit of evidence that
there are subtle changes that occur when
women ovulate non
women not on hormonal contraceptives but
it's mostly concealed but it is it is
largely concealed i think that's a
feature of bug in uh like do we evolve
that is that is that a
cool and a powerful invention for the
human species i think it's it's an
adaptation in women that women have
evolved concealed ovulation uh
and i think it's a feature not a bug
it gives more would it give more power
for women
to select
uh a mate there are a couple different
hypotheses about it but the one that i
think is
most plausible uh is that
you know if again comparing it to chimps
fema goes into estrus the male just has
to try to monopolize her while she's in
that estrus phase and then they
basically ignore the females after that
if you can't know when if when a woman
is fertile
then you have to stick around a lot
longer and so i think
long-term pair bonding
co-evolved with concealed ovulation
uh and with that
also a very different form of sexuality
which is that we have sex throughout the
uh the ovulatory cycle um and uh chimps
don't
you know there's there's a little bit of
mating a little bit of sex toward the
edges of the um estro cycle but but very
little so that that actually makes
mating
a more fundamental part of um
interaction between humans than it does
for chimps so meaning like
year-round every day i'm constantly
selecting amazing in terms of
biologically speaking so what what else
what else do men want
today in the 21st century versus
in the caveman days a wonderful question
to answer it though i have to
distinguish between
long-term mating and short-term mating
and in long-term mating it gets very
complicated
so as as a uh that's one way to put it
yeah
uh well well so i teach a course in
human sexuality at university of texas
at austin and
um one of the things this was back in
the days when there were chalkboards and
you and you taught with a piece of chalk
and wrote things on the board
and what i would do is i would ask the
class i'd teach this large class 1 to
200. i'd say what do women want
tell me what all the things women want
in a long-term mate
and so i would start at one end of the
blackboard there were like five
blackboards and they said well i want a
mate who's
who's kind who's understanding who's
intelligent who's healthy who's got a
good sense of humor who shares my values
and and i just go and fill five
blackboards and then run out of space
and and so you know the first this large
number of characteristics that people
want and then
specific magnitudes of those
characteristics or or amounts so i say
you you want a mate who's say generous
with their resources and they say yes i
want makes the research so i said so
like the guy who
this is in women's mate selection the
guy who at the end of every month gets
his paycheck and gives it to the uh
local wino um on on the dragons well no
not that generous okay generous toward
me
not not indiscriminately generous and so
you want a mate who's um
ambitious you know who's a hard worker
yes but but not a workaholic you know
and so uh and so then you get to
interactions among different
characteristics
so there's a lot of characteristics a
lot of variables in this very complex
optimization problem for women yes
that's right and more so for women than
for men so then when i turn it to men
and i say well what do men want and then
i i run out of space after about a
blackboard and a half because they they
can't think of anything else
so the women i think there's a lot of
explanations for that
besides the lack of the number of
variables it's also you know
um
i mean it's that's interesting so what
what's the difference between the
variables so on the men's side what are
the variables well they're in long-term
made selection there there's a lot of
overlap sure okay
um so
things like intelligence
um good health
sense of humor um
an agreeable personality someone who's
not too
neurotic or moody or or
emotionally volatile
but there are key differences as well
and the differences stem from they
basically fall on the delimited number
of domains so for men
it's physical attractiveness physical
appearance
and youth are the two real big ones okay
men prioritize those
more than women do and so that's why you
have phenomena such as uh this uh quote
love at first sight where sometimes men
can walk into a party and they see a
woman across the room and say that i'm
going to marry that woman that's the
woman for me women very rarely do that
now most men do don't do that either but
men are much more inclined to fall in
love at first sight that's because they
prioritize physical appearance
why because physical appearance provides
that this wealth of information
about a woman's fertility status and
this is from from an evolutionary
perspective from a purely reproductive
perspective
in in a business school they would call
it job one
job one is you have to select a fertile
mate
so those who in our evolutionary past
who selected infertile mates so
post-menopausal women for example
um did not become our ancestors so we
are all the descendants of this long and
unbroken chain of ancestors who all of
whom success succeeded in selecting a
fertile mate
but fertility cannot be observed
directly
uh it can't use some cues
exactly and and there are cues that are
probabilistically related to this
underlying quality of fertility that we
can't observe directly and we're doing
that computation in our heads what about
men
what do men want for short-term mating
well so for short-term mating um
for both sexes uh physical appearance uh
looms very large so so inc so women are
no physical attractiveness and
appearance they're important for women
in long-term mate selection so i don't
want to
um mislead anyone on that they're just
not as important as they are for men
and so a lot of characteristics come for
women before physical appearance
physical attractiveness